reason the next thing you say though I
think makes your point you say as you
saw yesterday the whole nonsense ended
with a very poor performance by a man
named Robert Muller an incompetent
performance but they say a lot of it
started with Ukraine whatever you can do
it's very important here's my question
and it did it ended with a very poor
performance and this is after more than
two years of an investigation where they
spent forty five million dollars or
something like that they had 2,500
subpoenas 500 witnesses all because
probably Hillary Clinton said just like
she did with Tulsi Gabbard just like she
did with Jill Stein she said Jill Stein
is a Russian asset no I don't know Jill
Stein I know her as an environmentalist
okay and probably a good woman the last
thing she is is a Russian asset I don't
know tulsi gabbard but I know one thing
she's not an asset of Russia these
people are sick there's something wrong
with that I want to show you this and
I'll put it up on our screen for people
at home Ukranian efforts to sabotage
Trump backfire this is this was January
11 2017 yep you weren't inaugurated yet
yep this article talks about how Ukraine
worked with Hillary to influence the
elections they give chapter and verse on
how they did it now don't you as the
president do you feel if there was
foreign interference in an election we
spent two and a half years hearing about
Trump Russia collusion they ignore the
dossier and Ukraine admitting that they
helped Hillary well the dossier was a
disgrace the dossier was totally fake
and now it's been proven to be fake
people know how that was done I mean
you'd have a track record now you know
as well as everybody knows I guess
they're doing an investigation but I
think before you even do the
investigation so they do a fake Tessier
and me they tried to release it before
the election to affect the election I
don't know how they didn't I say it's
probably the only thing I respect about
the press is they refuse to put it in
before the election because it could
have had a little impact maybe but I had
more than a little impact so they do a
fake dossier that was probably meant to
get out
I think definitely meant to get out
before the election so that they could
affect the election and look at the
people that wrote it and look at where
they came from and look at the wife of
the man that works I won't even mention
names at the Department of Justice and
she's on the payroll of the company that
Robert Muller never heard of during his
testimony in GPS think of it